la patria nuestra exclusiva de los
hombres
que somos nosotros entonces
muebles como gertrudis bocanegra muchas
mujeres dieron su vida por la
independencia de mexico ante españa pero
la mayoría no han tenido el
reconocimiento que merecen doscientos
años después de consumada la
independencia la actriz silvia pasquel
destaca la aportación de bocanegra y su
abandono y ella muere sin haber sido una
de la torá
y sin embargo pues no se habla mucho de
gertrudis bocanegra y yo estoy segura
que muchos de los mexicanos ni siquiera
saben que existe 42 vaca negra y es una
de las grandes heroínas de la
independencia en otra gran heroína y por
año renegado de la memoria histórica que
sea una vicario una de las primeras
periodistas quien aporta información
secreta a nuestros urgentes y financió
el movimiento de independencia durante
yo diría todo el siglo 19 y gran parte
del 20 la historia la historia
profesional y académica incluso crece de
la mano del estado
entonces es una historia sobre todo
política y la historia política tiende a
ser una historia de hombres
acorde con el avance del movimiento
feminista en 2020 el gobierno inauguró
el paseo de las heroínas en la avenida
más importante del país leona vicario
ahora tiene allí su estatua y aunque el
reconocimiento es loable para la
especialista en estudios de género lucía
melgar no es suficiente por más que haya
este tipo de gestos o que haya digamos
paridad en el congreso o que haya una
unas cuantas secretarias de estado pues
finalmente es una cáscara vacía de estas
estatuas porque pueden llamar la
atención de la gente pero no están
cambiando no están yendo junto con un
cambio para la mejoría de la vida de las
mujeres al margen de gobiernos en méxico
la agenda de género gana terreno en
distintos ámbitos y la historia no podía
ser la excepción